[Applause]
mr. president only members of the
European Parliament when I stood before
you this time last year I had the
somewhat easier speech to give
it was plain for all to see that our
union was not in a good state Europe was
battered and bruised by the truck our
very foundation we only had two choices
either come together around a positive
European agenda or each with it into our
own corners faced with this choice I
argued for unity I proposed a positive
agenda to help create as I said last
year a Europe that protects a Europe
that empowers a Europe that defends over
the past 12 month the European
Parliament has had in this agenda to
life we continue to make progress with
each passing day just last night you
worked to find an agreement on to a
different instrument and on doubling our
European investment capacity and to
succeed thank you for that I also want
to thank the 27 leaders of our Member
States these after my speech last year
they welcomed my agenda at their summit
in Bratislava in doing so they chose
unity they chose to rely around our
common God together result that you can
deliver for its citizens when and where
it matters ever since we've been slowly
but surely gathering momentum it helped
that the economic outlook swung in our
favor we are now in the
fifteen economic recovery that really
which is very and every single member
state growth in European Union has
outstripped that of the United States
over the last two years it now stands
about two percent for the Union as a
whole and at two point two percent for
the monetary area unemployment is at a
nine year low almost eight million jobs
have been created during this mandate so
far with 235 million people at work more
people are in employment in European
Union than ever before the European
Union European Commission cannot take
the credit for this alone though I'm
sure that had eight million jobs been
lost we would have taken the blame but
hoops institutions played their part in
helping the wind change we can take
credit for our European investment plan
which has triggered 225 billion worth of
investment so far it has wanted loans to
over 450 thousand small firms firms and
more than 270 infrastructure projects we
can take credit for the fact that thanks
to determined action European banks once
again have the capital firepower to lend
to companies so that they can grow and
create jobs and we can take what for
having bought public deficits down from
six point six percent to one point six
percent this is thanks to an intelligent
application of the stability and growth
pact we ask for fiscal discipline but
are careful not to kill growth this is
in fact working very well across the
Union despite some criticism 10 years
since crisis truck
you economics finally bouncing back and
with our confidence our 27 leaders the
Parliament and Commission are putting
the pack in our union and together we
are putting the Union back into our
union in the last year we saw all 27
leaders walk up to the Capitol Hill in
Rome one by one to renew their vows to
each other and to our union all of this
leads me to believe the wind is back in
your sights we have now a window of
opportunity but it will not stay open
forever let us make the most of the
momentum catch the wind in our sails for
this we must do two things first we
should stay the course at out last year
we have still 16 months in which real
progress can be made by Parliament
council and Commission we must use this
time to finish what we started in
Bratislava and deliver on our own
positive agenda secondly we should
charge the direction for the future as
Mark Twain word I'm quoting years from
now we'll be more disappointed by the
things we did not do done by those with
it now is the time to build a more
united a stronger and more democratic
Europe for 2025 mr. president president
ladies and gentlemen members of the
Parliament while we look toward the
future we cannot lose our direction
together we have set ourselves the
objective of achieving an energy union a
security union a capital markets union a
banking union
and a digital single market together
we've already traveled far on this road
as the Parliament has said the
Commission has already presented 80% of
the proposals that were set out at the
beginning of the mandate we now have to
work together in order to ensure that
these proposals become legislative acts
and that these acts are made concrete in
practice now as is ever the case some
concessions will have to be made the
proposals put forward by the Commission
to reform our common Asylum system or to
set up new solid rules on the posting of
workers are of course and I know this
controversial issues we will get good
results if everyone builds their part of
the bridge so that we can meet and I
would like to say that the Commission is
open to compromise starting from the
moment that the final result is good for
the Union and fair for all of its member
states we are now ready to submit the
remaining 20% of initiatives by May 2018
now this morning I spoke to the
president of the European Parliament I
unit a yani and the Prime Minister URI
rotters of Estonia and I sent a letter
of intention which sets out the
priorities for the upcoming year
I don't want and indeed I cannot here in
you read all of these proposals but do
allow me perhaps to mention five which
are particularly important first I would
like us to reinforce to strengthen
European trade program Europe is opened
to trade yes but there has to be
reciprocity we have to get as much as
what we give
trade is not an abstract concept trade
it's jobs trade is new opportunities for
European businesses whether the large
scale or small every million in export
that we have equals 14 thousand extra
jobs in Europe trade is also exporting
our social and environmental gnomes and
our rules in terms of the protection of
data and food safety Europe has always
been an attractive economic space but
since last year I see that our partners
all over the world are knocking at our
door in order to sign trade agreements
with us thanks to the help of this
Parliament we've just concluded a trade
agreement with Canada which will be
provisionally applicable starting next
week we found a political agreement with
Japan on a new future economic
partnership and by the end of this year
we have a very good chance to achieve
the same with Mexico and the countries
of South America today we're suggesting
that we open trade negotiations with
Australia and with New Zealand I would
like all of these agreements to be
finalized by the end of our mandate and
I am absolutely committed to them being
negotiated in the greatest transparency
this opening to exchanges has to go
hand-in-hand with increased transparency
for our decision-making processes the
European Parliament will have the last
word on all of these trade agreements
therefore its members just like national
and regional Parliament's have to be
kept absolutely up to speed and informed
started in the very first day of
negotiation and the Commission will
oversee this from now on the Commission
will publish all of the
negotiation mandates which it will
present to the council the citizen has
the right to know what the Commission is
putting forward we have finished with
the lack of transparency we're going to
finish with rumors and ideas of
intention that the complaints that the
Commission is very often is being the
subject of truth I'd like to say once
and for all that we are not naive
supporters of free exchange
Europe has always got to defend its
strategic interests this is why we
suggest today a new framework for the EU
on how we examine investments in English
is called investment screening if a
public business a foreign public
business wants to buy a strategic
european port part of our energy
infrastructure or one of our businesses
in for example defense technology that
can only happen in full transparency if
i a deep examination and debate this is
our political responsibility to know
what is happening here in order to be
able if we need to protect our
collective security
judge imanakum secondly the Commission
wants to make our industry stronger and
more competitive this is particularly
true for our industrial base and the 32
million workers who make up its backbone
they make the first-class products our
cars for example which explains where we
are ahead of others I am proud of our
car industry but I am shocked when
clients and consumers are intentionally
tricked Zagat's I never invite the
automobile industry to make proper
amends for that and to correct what
they're doing rather than trying to
trick and to lead people into error the
car constructors are to invest in clean
cars which are those of the future
present only them initially and
gentlemen we are going to present today
a new industrial strategy for Europe
which will allow our industry to remain
and become the very first in the area of
innovation digitalization and
decarbonisation thirdly I want Europe to
be a vanguard of the fight against
climate change last year we set a global
climate norms with the ratification of
the Paris agreement indeed in this very
assembly confronted by the reduction of
the ambitions which the United States
has shown Europe Europe is going to work
to ensure that the planet remains great
and it remains the indivisible
and of all humanity the Commission will
shortly present a proposal to reduce
carbon in the transport sector fourthly
I want us to protect better Europeans in
the digital area during the past few
years we have made progress in the
securitization of the Internet
there have been new rules put for by the
Commission which will protect our
intellectual property cultural diversity
and our private personal data we have
strengthened the struggle against
terrorist propaganda and online
radicalization but Europe remains pretty
equipped confronted by cyberattacks
cyberattacks are sometimes more
dangerous for the stability of democracy
and economies than guns and tanks only
last year we have noted more than 4000
attacks by cyber where at 80% of
Europeans enterprises have known at
least one incident linked to cyber
safety these cyber attacks do not know
borders and they spare nobody this is
why the Commission is proposing today
new tools and particularly a European
cyber security agency to better defend
us against these attacks and fifth
migration remains on our radar even if
the questions around migration of often
created debate and pandemic we have
managed to make real progress on
numerous fronts today we protect the
external frontiers in a more efficient
manner more than 1700 offices of the new
border guards and the coast guards work
with 100,000 national border guards in
all the Member States and
in Greece in Italy Bulgarian Spain we
have common borders with the states
you're not in the very front line of the
geographic situation they must not be
left alone for their protection we have
to have common frontiers and common
protection we have managed to slow down
the flows of irregular migrants which is
the source of great worry in many
countries we have reduced the number of
irregular arrivals by 97% in the eastern
Mediterranean thanks to the agreement
that we drew up with Turkey and this
summer we managed to better control the
central Mediterranean routes the
arrivals have gone down by 81 percent in
August compared to the same month last
year in this way we have considerably
reduced the number of human lives lost
in Mediterranean I can't talk about
migration without making a heartfelt
homage to Italy for its perseverance and
its generosity
well darling what did during summer
months the Commission worked in harmony
with the Prime Minister my friend paolo
gentiloni and his government we did it
will continue to do it because in the
Mediterranean Italy is saving the honor
of Europe we have also under gently
improved the living conditions of the
refugees in Libya I upset by the
terribly inhuman conditions which we see
in the reception centres here
Europe has got a collective
responsibility and the Commission will
work hand-in-hand with the United
Nations to bring to name this scandalous
situation which cannot continue even if
it saddens me that not all of our Member
States show the same degree of
solidarity Europe as a whole has
continued to shown solid to show
solidarity only last year Member States
gave asylum to over 700 20,000 refugees
or have foreseen how they would be
replaced these three times more than
Australia Canada and the United States
together Europe
contrary to what is often said is not a
fortress and must never become one
Europe is and will remain the continent
of solidarity where you people have to
be able to find asylum if people are
being accept are being pursued for
unacceptable reasons
Jassi Putnam and I'm particularly proud
of those young Europeans who are
volunteering to give language courses to
Syrian refugees or to all those young
people who by the thousands have joined
our new European solidarity corps these
young people give of life and color to
European solidarity
[Applause]
Minda valladolid fo but today we've got
to double our efforts for the end of the
monthly press commission will present a
new series of proposals focused on
returns solidarity of Africa and the
opening up of paths of legal migration
in particular come to the issue of
returns I won't repeat this those who
have no right to stay in Europe I've got
to go back to their country of origin
only 36 percent of migrants in her
regular situation are sent back it is
obvious that we have to considerably
strengthened our activities in this area
this is the only way that Europe will be
able to show proof of solidarity with
regard to the refugees who really need
protection
the Solidarity in the closet solidarity
cannot be an exclusively entry European
issue it's also about putting in place
greater solidarity with Africa Africa
cradle of humanity a noble coordinate a
young continent trust fund for Africa
which has been filled with 2.7 billion
euros opened the possibilities of jobs
all over the African continent but while
the budget of the EU is carrying the
weight of the financing the contribution
of all of our member states is only at
150 million euros so the trust is now
getting to its limits
we knew we have to know the risks are
there being a lack of financing in 2015
many migrants wanted to get to Europe
when and because the third funds of the
UN ran out I've ever want to invite the
Member States to join action to words
and to ensure that the trust fund for
Africa does not suffer the main fate
because the risk is great
News LOC travel alert we're also going
to work toward the opening of legal
migration routes irregular migration
will only stop when the migrants have
got another option than undertaking a
perilous journey surely when the point
of setting up 20 mm a few G's coming
from Turkey Jordan and Lebanon and I am
actually supporting also the High
Commissioner than it shouldn't for the
reinstallation of 40,000 other refugees
from Libya and neighboring countries for
the rest Europe is a continent which is
getting older and this is another reason
for having a legal migration system
which is an absolute necessity this is
why the Commission has brought for
proposals to facilitate access for
migrants to the European blue card and I
want to thank the support of the
Parliament for this proposal didn't mr.
president ladies and gentlemen
honourable members I have just listed a
small number of initiatives that we have
that we want to complete by the end of
next year and we have to do that but
even that is not enough if we're to win
the hearts and minds of the people of
Europe the time has come to set the
course for the future in March the
Commission published its white paper on
the future of Europe with five different
scenarios setting out how Europe might
look in 2025 these scenarios were
debated sometimes superficially
sometimes in depth they were analyzed
and sometimes they were torn apart and
that is the way things should be because
that's what they were for
we have to set in train a process which
will allow the people of Europe
themselves to determine their future the
future of Europe is not something that
can be dictated from above any such
decision must be based on a broad
consensus in the wake of democratic
debate this house has made an active
contribution to this debate and I'd like
to thank all of the reporters concerned
I'd also like to thank those members
who've taken part in the more than 2,000
public stakeholder consultations which
the Commission has organized around
Europe since March the time has come
ladies and gentlemen to draw the first
conclusions from this debate the time
has come to take the next step from
reflection to action from debate to
decision let me now set out the way I
see things you're about to hear my own
my very personal scenario number six
this is born out of decades of personal
experience I have lived the European
project through my entire life I have
fought for it I have worked for it I've
been through good times and I've been
through bad times I've sat on various
sides of the negotiating table as
Minister as Prime Minister as president
of the Eurogroup and now as president of
the European Commission I was there at
Maastricht at Amsterdam nice and Lisbon
where our union developed and expanded I
have always fought for Europe I have
sometimes suffered with Europe and
agonized over Europe I have been through
thick and thin with the European Union
never have I lost my love for the
European Union as we all know there is
no love without disappointment all very
rarely love for Europe I mean what I say
because the European Union has achieved
so much in this divided world inward and
outward peace prosperity not for all but
still for many in 2018 we should
consider what it means to have a
European year of cultural heritage and
celebrate our cultural diversity the
Vertigo Europe is a Europe of values and
a safe place for us to be Europe is more
than the single market than money than
the euro it's all about values there are
three fundamental principles which
underpin my scenario number six freedom
equality of opportunity and the rule of
law
first and foremost Europe is a union of
freedom and by that I mean freedom from
oppression and dictatorship those are
phenomena that our continent especially
its central and eastern parts have known
all too well and I mean the freedom
under slight height and I mean the
freedom to speak our minds where there
are citizens or as journalists this is
not to be taken for granted and yet it
is these values of freedom upon which
our union is built freedom is not
something handed down to us we have to
fight for it in Europe and in the world
hope was a new Europe must be a union of
equality and equality of opportunity
that means equality between its members
be they big be they small be they in the
East the West the North or the South
Europe stretches from Vigo to Varna from
Spain to Bulgaria
Europe needs to breathe with both its
lungs the eastern lung and the Western
lung otherwise our continent will
suffocate in a union of equality there
cannot be second-class citizens it is
unacceptable that in 2017 children are
dying in Europe from diseases which
should have been eradicated long ago
Kindle children in Romania and children
in Italy should have the same access to
measles vaccines like children in other
European countries with no ifs and no
buts the soak up and that is why we are
working together with all of the Member
States to support their national
vaccination programmes there must not be
avoidable deaths in our Europe
you know no underglow in a Europe of
equality there cannot be second-class
workers people doing the same work in
the same place should receive the same
remuneration Liz until that is what is
behind the Commission's proposals on the
posting of workers we need to make sure
that all EU rules on worker mobility are
implemented fairly simply and
effectively and for that we need a new
European supervisory and implementation
authority it is absurd for us to have a
banking supervisory authority making
sure that banking's and standards are
respected when we don't have a common
labor market authority which makes sure
that the single market is built on
fairness the villages we are going to
set up such an authority in a union of
equality there can be no second-class
consumers I for one cannot accept that
people especially in Central and Eastern
Europe are buying poorer quality
products which have the same packaging
and the same label as those sold in
other countries a Slovak deserves to
have as much fish in fish fingers as
anyone else
a Hungarian should have as much meat in
meat dishes as anyone else and Czechs
should have as much cocoa in their
chocolate as anyone else that these this
these practices are already forbidden by
EU law and we have to make sure that
that EU law is enforced and we need to
ensure the national authorities have the
wherewithal to root out these practices
in Europe law has muscle it's not muscle
that lays down the law and that means
that in Europe the law is safeguarded by
an independent judiciary being part of a
union which is built on the rule of law
means respecting court judgments our
member states have given the European
Court of Justice the powers to take the
ultimate decision and that means ecj
judgments have to be respected in all
cases failing to respect them and
undermining the national justice systems
means stealing citizens fundamental
rights in the European Union the rule of
law is not optional it's a duty our
union is not a state but it can but it's
still governed by the rule of law these
are drug law these three principles
freedom equality of opportunity and rule
of law have to remain the foundation of
our ever stronger and ever more United
and more democratic Union for the people
of Europe what they're looking for is
not new treaties new institutions there
are means to an end
new institutions new treaties are
perhaps of interest to us here in
Strasbourg or in Brussels elsewhere
people don't care two hoots I'm only
interested in institutional reform if it
gives if it gives us a more efficient
Union one day there will be treaty
change but to busy ourselves with the
now it means first and foremost that we
have to understand that democracy is
based on compromise not winners and
losers if we have the right compromises
everyone is a winner in the European
Union compromises are neither bad nor
ugly compromises are an art a way of
bridging differences and finding our way
to one another people who struggle with
compromises struggle with democracy and
struggle with Europe if we are to have a
stronger European Union it needs to be
more inclusive - if we want to bolster
our external borders and rightly so then
it is high time to bring Romania and
Bulgaria into the Schengen area
[Applause]
and incidentally Croatia too deserves
full membership of the Schengen area as
soon as all of the criteria are met
[Applause]
if we want the euro to unite our
continent rather than dividing it then
it needs to be more than just the
currency of a select group of country
the euro is destined to be the common
currency of the entire European Union
all but two Member States are duty-bound
to join the euro area as soon as they've
met the conditions for that to be
possible
these Member States need the support of
a euro accession instrument which I
propose here today which will offer
pre-accession assistance in technical
and financial form if we want the
continents banks to operate by the same
rules and under the same supervision
then we should encourage all Member
States to accede to the banking union
that means we must reduce the remaining
risks in the banking systems of certain
Member States the banking union will
only work if risk reduction and risk
mitigation goes hand-in-hand for us to
be able to ensure that that is the case
a certain number of preconditions have
to be in place as proposed by the
Commission in November 2015 we can only
have a common Deposit Guarantee Scheme
when all of the Member States have done
their homework if we want to see an end
to social fragmentation and social
dumping in Europe the Member States as
soon as possible and at the latest by
the Gothenburg summit in November should
agree on the European
of social rights national social
security systems are going to continue
to have their differences and will
continue to be separate but we should
still at least agree on a european union
of social standards to ensure that we
have a consensus about what is socially
fair and what isn't socially fair on our
single market plywood duffel you got
soaked dammit I hope a girl ink a
successful Europe must not give workers
the cold shoulder ladies and gentlemen
if we want to have greater stability in
our neighborhood then we need to offer a
credible enlargement prospect to the
countries of the Western Balkans during
the term of office of this commission
and this Parliament there will be no new
accessions because the conditions for
accession will not have been met however
in future the European Union will have
more than 27 member states in the case
of all accession countries the rule of
law justice and fundamental values have
top priority in the negotiations and
that rules out EU membership for Turkey
in the foreseeable future
get up go for some considerable time
turkey has been moving away from the
European Union in leaps and bounds
journalists belong in editorial offices
amidst a heated debate and not in prison
[Applause]
I appeal today to the powers that be in
Turkey let our journalists go and not
just our journalists stop calling our
Member States and our heads of state and
government fascists and Nazis Europe is
a continent of mature democracies those
who knowingly offend pull up the
drawbridge and sometimes I have the
impression that there are those in
Turkey who want to pull up the
drawbridge and later blame the European
Union for the failure of accession
negotiations from our side there will
always be an outstretched hand
outstretched to the great people of
Turkey and all of those who are willing
to work with us on the basis of our
shared values man as if calm down and
tell the ladies and gentlemen honourable
members I would like to see our union
stronger and that means it needs a
stronger single market in matters of the
single market we need more frequent and
simpler decision-making on the basis of
a qualified majority with European
Parliament co-decision and that doesn't
need a doesn't necessitate treaty change
the existing treaties contain bridging
clauses which make it possible to decide
in Council on the basis of quarter
five majority as long as this is decided
in advance by unanimity in the European
Council I'm thinking in terms of
decisions about value-added tax fair
taxation of the digital economy and the
financial transaction tax these can all
be decided by qualified majority
tomislav Europe needs to be able to take
decisions more rapidly and more
efficient more efficiently we need to
see a more agile economic and monetary
union the euro area is more resistant to
shocks than it was a few years ago we
have a European Stability Mechanism
which I believe should gradually be
turned into a European monetary fund
that needs to be anchored in the
European Union there will be specific
proposals coming from the Commission in
December of this year to that effect
we need a European Minister of Economy
and Finance a minister to promote
structural reform in our member states a
minister who can build on the work done
in the Commission by its special unit
two first structural reforms support the
European Minister of Economy and finance
should coordinate all EU financing
instruments and step in whenever a
member state is facing the threat of
recession or fundamental crisis and here
I'm not calling for a new position for
efficiency reasons I believe that the
future Commissioner responsible for
economic economy and finance ideally a
vice-president of the European
Commission carry out this role the
patient as well
chairing the Eurogroup the European
Minister of Economy and finance must of
course be accountable to the European
Parliament we do not need parallel
structures we do not need a separate
euro budget we need a strong eurozone
budget line within the existing EU
budget it's gone lobbed at you do nor do
I see great merit in the idea of a
separate euro Parliament the Parliament
of the euro area is this one the
European Parliament the European Union
also needs to be stronger in how it
fights terrorism in the last three years
a great deal has already been done but
we're still not reacting so long and
slow quickly enough in the case of
cross-border terror threats I therefore
plead for the setting up of a European
investigating body that would make sure
that data on terrorists and foreign
fighters are automatically exchanged
between our intelligence and police
services I smile or just I also believe
that there are there is reason enough
for the newly set up European public
prosecutor to be responsible for the
prosecution of cross-border terrorist
crimes the European Union the European
Union should also have more influence on
the world stage but it needs to be able
to take its foreign policy decisions
more swiftly I think it the time has
come to take foreign policy decisions in
certain cases by qualified majority and
that is allowed under the existing
treaties as long as there is a unanimous
decision by the European
and there is reason to do that it would
make our work more efficient in the
field of defense more efforts are
required the setting up of a European
Defense Fund is on our agenda permanent
structured cooperation in the defense
field is well underway by 2025 we will
need a functioning European defense
Union we need it and NATO would like us
to have it the Union should continue to
do what the Commission has sought to do
lately I to concentrate on the important
things we shouldn't annoy the people of
Europe with nitpicking and nitty-gritty
we need to we need to act on the big
things and keep away from the small
things which can be dealt with by the
Member States this commission has tried
to play a great role in the big things
and to take a back seat on the small
things each year it's put forward fewer
than 25 new initiatives remember the
previous commission was putting out more
than a hundred this month we're going to
be setting up a subsidiary and
proportionality task force the first
vice-president France timmermans has
already done a good job of better
lawmaking and he's going to lead the new
task force the timmermans task force
will have among its members members of
this Parliament and members of national
parliaments it will report in one year
mr. president president ladies and
gentlemen our union now needs to affect
a democratic leap I hope that European
political parties will kick off their
campaigns for the next elections earlier
than they did in the past because all
too often European electoral campaigns
have been reduced to a simple totting up
of national electoral proposals and
European democracy deserves a lot more
than that today the Commission is
setting out new rules on the funding of
parties and political foundations
it's not a question of boosting the
Treasuries of the extremists that are
against Europe it's a question of
allowing European parties to better
structure themselves I'm well aware that
the idea is contested by a number of
people but I have to say that I have
quite a lot of sympathy for the idea of
having transnational lists for European
elections and I will try and convince
the leader of my parliamentary group to
try and follow this idea because it will
lead to the more clarity and more
democracy for our elections I also think
that over the next few months we should
involve national parliaments and civil
society at the national regional and
local level we should involve them in
the work that we're doing on the future
of Europe over the last three years
members of the Commission
have visited national parliaments more
than 650 times they participated in more
than 300 meetings talking to citizens in
more than 80 cities in 27 member states
and that's why I support president
Mekons idea of organizing Democratic
conventions throughout Europe in 2018 as
the debate develops I will be attaching
a great deal of importance personally to
Estonia Latvia Lithuania and Romania in
2018 because 2018 is the year where
these four countries will be celebrating
their 100th birthday those who have the
ambition to shape our future and our
continent need to know about and honor
our history our joint history and so the
history of the four countries I
mentioned also is part and parcel of
that of course these are countries
without which Europe would not be
complete this need to reinforce
democracy and transparency obviously
also has implications for the European
Commission today I am handing out to the
European Parliament a new code of
conduct for commissioners first and
foremost this code of conduct specifies
that commissioners can stand in European
elections under perfectly normal
conditions obviously the new code will
shore up the obligations of
Commissioners when it comes to integrity
during and after their mandate whoever
wants to boost European democracy could
never accept that the major democratic
progress inherent in the heads of lists
and the schvitzing candidate got candy
Darton system would never go along with
that not being renewed because it was an
innovation and led to more democracy and
I'm convinced but by them myself by the
way will not be a candidate but I'm
convinced that the future president will
make the most of this experience here's
on TV you can stand if you like but you
won't be elected more democracy that's
what we need and that means more
efficiency of course European efficiency
would would would would be very much at
an advantage if we were to merge
together the presidencies of the
European Commission and European Council
that would lead to a massive boost in
efficiency this proposal does not target
in any way my excellent friend Donald
Tusk who I've been working with very
harmoniously for over the last three
years right from the start of our
mandate it is not this proposal is not
aimed at myself and it's not aimed at
Donald but all it does is ensure that
European landscape the European
landscape would be clearer and more
understandable if the European ship was
steered by one in the same captain at
the helm so if we just had a single
president it would better reflect the
true nature of our European Union which
is a union of states and a union of
citizens
colleagues the vision of a more unified
Europe a stronger Europe a more
democratic Europe this is what I'm
presenting to you today and it involves
all the different scenarios that I set
out last March but our future cannot
remain a mere scenario some kind of
draft one idea among many others it's
today that we have to start preparing
our union of tomorrow this morning I
sent president tae Yanni president tasks
and also to the future presidencies in
Council of the council from now until
March 2019 I sent them a roadmap setting
out the direction that we need to follow
and one important element in this is the
budget that the Commission will be
presenting in May 2018 there too we have
a choice to make here either
we ensure that the European ambitions
the European Union's ambitions are given
a comenta budget commensurate to those
ambitions and that is something that I'm
very much in favor of we shouldn't be
making any cuts that would be the other
option which I would not be in favor of
March March 29th 2019 that were the date
whether Europe where the United Kingdom
will leave the European Union this will
be a very sad and tragic moment in our
history we will always regret this but
and I think that you will regret it as
well soon if I might say
[Applause]
many volatile nonetheless we have to
respect the will of the British people
but we are going to make progress we
will keep moving we will move on because
brexit isn't everything it's not the
future of Europe it's not the bill on
end or the 32 March 2019 on that date
will be a union of 27 and I suggest that
we prepare very well for that date the
European Parliament elections will will
have taken place just a few weeks later
in May 2009 teen that date will be a
very important meeting with European
democracy we need to ensure that
European citizens go to the ballot box
having a very clear vision of the way in
which the European Union will develop in
the years to come and that's why I am
calling on President tusk and on Romania
which will be which will have the
presidency during the first half of the
year 2019 I want them to organize a
special summit in Romania on the 30th of
March 2019 and I would like that summit
to be held in the Magnificent ancient
city of Sibiu which I also know under
the name of hair monster that would be
the right moment to take very important
decisions essential decisions in fact to
shape Europe and more united Europe a
stronger and more democratic Europe my
hope is that on the 30th of March 2019
Europeans will wake up in a union where
they know that we're defending their
values we're all member states
vigorously respect the rule of law where
being a member a full member of the
eurozone the banking Union and the
Schengen area have become a standard for
every member state of the European Union
we need to ensure that we defend our
single currency in all circumstances
good and bad without having recourse to
external aid single market needs to be
fairer for workers in the East and the
West
and I hope that they will wake up in a
world like that we also need to agree on
a bedrock of social standards where
profits are texts where they are
generated where terrorists find no fault
lines to exploit and where we will have
agreed on the creation of a true
European defence Union where a single
president will be at the helm of the
work of the Commission and the council
after having been elected in the wake of
a pan-european electoral campaign so yes
on the 30th of March 2019 our citizens
will wake up in that kind of union and
if that's the case they will need to
take part in the elections to vote and
they need to realize that our union is
working for them ladies and gentle
Helmut Kohl and Jacques dolor taught me
that Europe will only advance if it
shows courage the single market the
Schengen area the single currency all of
these things were projects when they
were first initiated or when they were
first thought of as mere flights of
fancy
but all those projects that I mentioned
are a reality nowadays so Europe is is
faring better now and people are telling
me where one shouldn't overload our
European ship but at the same time this
stage that we have now reached dictates
that we shouldn't be over cautious it's
not enough just to make mine
repairs what we should do today and
tomorrow is patiently step by step from
one inspiration to the next moving
onwards and complete not just the roof
of our European house but proceed in
building and completing all of the
floors of that house we need to finish
the job as a whole now that the sun is
shining this is where we need to do it
because when the next storm brews and it
certainly will it will have been it will
be too late so let's raise anchor let's
get going let's set sail let's get going
and let's catch the wind in our sails
thank you very much
[Applause]
get out [ __ ] Thank You president of the
Commission thank you for your speech
which now gives us the opportunity to
have an important debate on the future
of our European Union you have given us
in this room very many elements for
discussion of great interest and we will
listen now to the words of the
representatives of the European citizens
as president of the Parliament all I can
do is to share your position on the need
to have a more democratic Europe I want
to thank you for having underlined this
necessity I share and I thank you again
for a number of the things that you said
more than one thing that you said
because you have repeated the positions
of the Parliament on a number of key
issues the fact that the Parliament can
also have its power of initiative this
is something that we want to count on
the support of the Commission in order
to be able to launch initiatives in
areas of great importance thank you now
I will give the floor to the chairs of
the political groups the first mr. Weber
for the TPP here requires courage
it requires optimism and creativity
we've heard that in JA called Yonkers
speech I thank you very much for this
new start and I'd like to thank the
Commission as a whole for the work that
is done for our continent trust
colleagues can only be generated through
deeds the Paris climate agreement
theater better Border Protection growth
in Europe reduction of unemployment well
it's true that a lot of people are
faring better in Europe today than in
previous years and we are delivering and
when I say we I mean the European
Parliament which is the people's chamber
of Europe it is something that we are
delivering it's only through our work
that there is a young Commission the
first political Commission is the child
of this house of this democracy in
Europe and that's why I think we can be
proud of what we have achieved together
the Parliament and the Commission are
working together moving in the same
direction
as far as the EPP is concerned I welcome
the ideas set out by our president the
president of the Commission for
deepening the European Union the world
is not resting on its laurels it's not
waiting for us we have to make progress
ourselves I as far as the EPP is
concerned wants to take up the cudgels
for Europe for people people are worried
about globalization they're worried
about unemployment they're worried about
social dumping and we have the idea of a
social market safe job secure jobs a
decent wage a fair wage property if you
have property it means certain
obligations we need to be able to stand
up to the large players we are saying
yes to world trade but we want to
protect our core industries we want to
protect the social standards in the
European Union the European way of life
is a social one and I would like to see
us as the EPP in the center point of
that a lot of people are worried about
the the the images that they see illegal
immigrants that are either don't
believe politicians anymore when they
say this is good for us they are worried
they worried about their culture they
are worried about their identity and
that's why we need to do all we can to
protect our borders to police our
borders it's not a case of building up a
wall around Europe but illegal migration
needs to be stopped the European Way of
life helps people when they are in an
emergency situation when they need help
but this doesn't mean to say that we
should be helping people traffickers
that we should be helping illegal
immigration integration means as well
that the values and the traditions and
cultures of our societies are respected
States should citizenship in Europe
should be linked to these values anyone
who does not subscribe to those values
should leave Europe another concern that
is expressed by people is Turkey a lot
of people are shocked when they look at
Turkey it seems that arbitrarily people
are being thrown into prison change of
the Constitution the rule of law has
been undermined Turkey is moving away
from Europe and people don't understand
why Europe isn't doing anything we are a
European Parliament and we've made it
clear that we should suspend accession
talks because we want to send out a
signal that we cannot continue along
these lines in these circumstances and
jean-claude Juncker I think people are
worried and concerned that the
Commission in the Parliament and the
European Union as a whole is not taking
sufficient action or speedy action
Salona Turku this summer many say that
Islam is a danger during the attack on
Charlie Hebdo in Paris two years ago a
French Polish man was executed by the
terrorists his name was Ahmed Maribeth
he was a Muslim who gave his life to
defend the freedom of journalists dear
friend it's not a conflict between
Christians and Muslims it's a clone
flicked between humanity and barbarism
between values and terrorism between our
European Bay
of life and the madness of the
terrorists we must exchange our
informations now immediately and that
the protection must not be turned into
protection of the terrorists say
European Way of life protects the
freedom of religion it does not know the
national egoism when fighting together
against the terrible acts of the
terrorists and dear friends many people
as a last perspective from the people's
point of view are afraid when they are
looking east was in some days a maneuver
of Russian and Belarusian army will
start at the borders to our Baltic
States about 100,000 soldiers directly
at our border many people are afraid
after the wars in Georgia in Ukraine in
Syria what is put in planning now dear
friends the European Way is to defend
ourself and that's why the ideas of see
European defense union are going in a
good direction we need them now your
friends we need them now
and this is also why we should stop
North stream to our security to your
friends as priority to making money and
finally there are a few of other
perspectives from people's point of view
what they asked us to do and we have to
give proper answers let's act now but to
all these points I think it says a need
to have a to help to combine them to
bring them together and that is from a
PvP point of view to define and to
defend in the future the European Way of
life in the past our founding fathers of
the European Union achieved peace say
are they were successful because they
believed in themselves today dear
friends we must defends the identity of
Europe today we must defend the European
Way of life in the world that is
changing rapidly and we will also be
successful let's start now the
I know mate I know in the name of the
S&T group mr. patella thank you
president Juncker it's true there is a
wind of hope a new wind of hope blowing
over Europe and citizens are beginning
to have the idea that without Europe
they'll be more in their own unless
defended but we don't need to be
realistic about this we've done well but
we have only got one bullet in the gun
and we can't shoot it wrong it is
important that we ensure that a lot of
the ideas for Europe are coming from our
group the socialist groups we say that
we have to transform the proposals into
results and as you said let's be
courageous with this let's strike all
the multinationals who have defrauded
the tax systems meaning that they've
actually used their benefits that should
be going to the benefits of the European
citizen this has gone to the
exploitation of young people young
people even those with masters end up
earning 550 euros a month this is a
scandal there's the scan that we have to
oppose we have to as the European
commissioners mr. Tim Owens is doing we
have to look at the issue of freedom
equality the rule of law democracy you
said that these are the pillars of the
scenario that you've painted I would say
these are the foundation this the very
DNA of the European idea
we have reinforced decisional Pro
says we have we ought to have a European
Minister of budgets but this isn't just
to be a kind of obscure guardian of the
treaties it has got to be a democratic
institution that actually gives physical
transparency I say this clearly we do
not want a minister which actually
becomes a kind of policeman we want a
minister which is actually focused on
growth and work we have to get out of
the rhetoric of the three A's that were
being talked about on social welcome to
the social world mr. Weber I'd like to
say welcome to the EPP I look forward to
you pushing behind us as we have been
pushing on these dossiers over the years
in the areas of the company of the
Commission we have to have a child
guarantee for young men and women no
child should be left without education
without home without food this also
plays unaccompanied minors they have
also got to be given these things we
have to be more courageous when it comes
to investment we have to be more
critical comes to fighting climate
change there's problems and wonderful
work in that area we have to ensure we
can actually look what's happening with
hurricanes you have to be able to
foresee the disasters Europe has got to
be a leader in this battle and now on
immigration thank you for recognizing
Italy am I saying this as a European not
as an Italian but we have to do more
there has to be a revision of the treaty
and the Dublin regulations but the
socialist group will not vote any
decision without the elimination of the
ever get rid of the country of the first
safe country it has to be legal ways of
migration and the blue card is an old
tool we have to have the courage to open
legal routes for migration that's the
fair thing to do but if we don't have
these legal migration channels were not
going to solve the problem and that's
why we have to have a partnership with
Africa which I would define as the
partnership of dignity you said there
has to be money yes it's very important
that we ensure that there is funds I
think it's we need to ask the young
entrepreneurs who are creating jobs and
development in Africa we have to have a
proper a cohesion policy we have to have
the budget with its own proper resources
and we have to think properly about the
financial transaction tax we have to
President Juncker we have to say yes to
transparency on the trade agreements
this is a we're defending this and the
interests of the citizen we have to go
over and above what's been done with a
chata
the soldiers want to go over and above
chatter when it comes to the protection
of the interests of the citizen and the
consumer thank you for your patience but
we have got a white page and we can
write this white page together you
talked about innovation you talked about
the huge progress pay I very often we
talk about this here but very often is
like we're kind of you know
discussing amongst the angels by the
world moves ahead without us what we can
do what we can't do it if God to do we
have to be part of this huge
transformation is taking place look at
the agenda 2030 for sustainable
development let us take that as an
example let's work with that with the
love that you have in your heart but
also the commitment that we have in the
socialist group to work together let's
ensure we do this with real with reality
and conviction I know in the name of the
floor goes to mr. Kamath Thank You mr.
Yonko when it comes to jobs security and
freedom au protects cannot be a Europe
that is protectionist and the ECR group
believes that the EU needs to create
more opportunities not more regulations
and more agencies
many of our citizens tell us that they
feel as if they have little say in the
decisions we make about their lives
their countries and their futures when
it comes to their concerns over
migration security and jobs they prefer
an EU that complements their national
and local governments not seek to
overrule them speaking as both a future
neighbor who wishes to see a prosperous
EU trade in and cooperating with a
prosperous UK and speaking today as one
the leaders of the EC are group with MEP
s from across the EU being critical of
the policies of the EU should not be
seen as an attack on the EU but a
genuine desire to see an EU which
regains a trust and confidence of its
citizens as a liberal conservative and a
passionate believer in free trade I
welcome the emphasis on open trade in
your speech but modern open trade needs
countries to shed the cloak of
protectionism modern open trade needs to
be open to the latest investment in
technology to allow frictionless borders
modern open trade needs faster broadband
networks to our SMEs to situate securely
online with the rest of the world and
for businesses and our economies to
thrive let us prioritize the refit
agenda let us improve access to finance
for businesses small and large via
peer-to-peer lending and crowdfunding
let us train our workers with the skills
demanded by modern digital economies but
also let us unleash the spirit of free
enterprise in our young people to create
their own businesses and let them be
allowed to try and try again
if at first they don't succeed because
just as Soviet five-year plans did not
create a creative economies EU growth
plans don't create jobs its businesses
that create jobs
we must also remember that our economic
prosperity depends upon global stability
and we cannot show disunity in our
dealings with Russia or other unpleasant
regimes we must maintain sanctions and
show in words and in action at the
Eastern Partnership summit that for
countries like Ukraine NATO the EU and
the West can offer them a better
stronger and more stable future than
turning to face the East Mr Yunker no
one expects there to be a quick fix to
all the challenges or for youth to have
all the answers by the next time we meet
but the people outside of this building
want to know that the people inside this
building will continue to study the ship
and not set sail until yet more storms
so no matter what side of the argument
or what side of the channel all our
countries need to prepare to face the
global challenges from a position of
optimism from a position of strength and
from a position of honesty without
voters
I know methyl group order alia and now
for the Aldi group the floor to mr.
hofstadt president first of all
jean-claude what the difference with
last year I like I like your speech your
State of the Union I think it was full
of vision ambition for 2019 and quite a
difference with with wit last year but
let's be honest between us a lot has
changed in fact in the meanwhile in this
in the Union last year in August for
example 2016 it was mr. Hoover who said
that he wanted to take Austria out of
the of the euro and union and five
months later after his defeat he said
exactly the opposite he changed his mind
and he said no no we want to stay in the
euro and in the Union and then in March
of this year in the Netherlands
it was mr. Wilgus who promised a spring
of populism and what he created he
reaped the opposite it were the Pro
European parties who won the election
and in France exactly the same it was
Emmanuel macron who won the campaign
which in pro-european program and since
then even the from national doesn't want
to exit the euro and union anymore and
even in Hungary Viktor Orban is piping
down he accepts now the authority of the
European Court of Justice and he said I
think two days ago on a radio interview
that no way that ever-hungry would leave
the Union so I want to say in fact at
the occasion of this state of the union
jean-claude - mr. Hofer
- mrs. Lipan - Viktor Orban welcome to
the side of reason even when we know all
of us that is not that have changed
their mind it's not by conviction that
they're changed and mind but by fear of
losing votes that they have changed
their mind now and the only way or the
only one for the moment we still doesn't
get it I think is Mr Farage he is still
going on
he said last weekend he called the
German EFD to campaign on brexit I think
it's a fantastic advice to campaign on
grexit you have to keep up the good work
Nigel I hope they take it but
unfortunately I don't think that they
are so stupid to do that in Germany with
the AFD and because let's be honest it's
clear what our citizens want they don't
want to destroy Europe they want to
reform Europe but to destroy it no
bloody way that is the message of our
myth all citizens and colleagues and
that is what I like so much in the State
of the Union this year by jean-claude
Juncker let's not make the mistake to
think ok yeah the war is over we have
won a few elections in a number of
countries and now the wind is blowing in
the right direction
no what the people want is not to
continue with this Europe they want to
reform to European you European Union
73% of our citizens want more European
action on the side of migration 75% want
more European action against climate
change the same number want a European
army and at the same time even more
Europeans want European capacities and
capabilities in the fight against
terrorism so it is true a Zonk load that
the last three years were not easy it
was mainly crisis management but I
completely agree with you that it is now
the moment now or never I should say
like in the song to build up that
European Union that the people are
asking for and that we together are
already dreaming of for a number of
years and what does it mean it means
that we create a European Asylum system
so that we can finally get rid of this
broken Dublin system because there is
the real origin of the problem Dublin is
not European
that's national egoism that is Dublin
but not Dublin as a safety net don't
misunderstand me because I gonna have my
Irish friends again me if I continue
like that
a European border and coastguards and a
system of legal indeed gianni migration
so that people no longer die on also
because every dead body that we find in
the Mediterranean is a scandal for us
for Europe even one that in the daily
terrain a European defense Union so that
it are not the Americans and the
Russians war in fact deciding missus
mogherini in our backyard what is still
the case today
a European FBI why because terrorists
don't know borders that's the reality so
why we continue to do so and then also a
real government for the eurozone so that
we can steer the European economy and
that we can create what in fact we are
missing European champions it are our
competitions rules were too narrow in
fact it is the fact that we have no
unified markets with single regulators
who make that we have no European
champions that can become world
champions and compete on the world level
but there is one thing on which I have a
little difference of point of view were
you and that is on the institutional
problem I'm always thinking that good
institutions produce good policies and
that bad institutions create in fact
still stand stagnation and crisis and
there are a number of examples of that
and that's the reason why we in this
Parliament and I thank you for the
support really because it's very helpful
that we want also to create
transnational lists and a real European
constituency and why we want to do that
because it's time to lift D D democracy
to a continental scale Europe dear
colleagues is more than the sum of 27
national democracies we are more than
that we are in fact a democracy on a
European scale also to defend our values
and our principles outside the Union but
also inside the Union this European
democracy is necessary for example to
withstand
outright governments like we see today
also inside in Poland and in Hungary
would think in fact that Trump which his
white supremacy is the example or put in
an urban would jail opponents is the
example well that will never be the
example in whatever Member State in
European Union and for that reason we
have to create this European democracy
with a transnational in fact
responsibility because we need as
Emmanuel macron has said it nearly to
the Acropolis because we need to be the
counterweight of all these developments
and yeah autocratic leaders worldwide a
beacon of openness a beacon of freedom
and a beacon of hope in the 21st century
thank you present and thank you
jean-claude juncker for the State of
Union
they're a group thank you know for the
GUI ng al the floor no mystery Ike um
mr. president President of the European
Commission you have painted a canvas
which does not represent what the people
of the European Union are living through
you cannot paint a canvas so made up of
statistics
I'm afraid the workers who are who see
their jobs are under threat the small
farmers who see themselves being priced
out of the market the unemployed for
whom nothing is being done these people
see a different picture and however many
billions you place upon the altar what
can we actually say we have achieved
when people can't make ends meet that's
the crisis in the European Union the
crisis that sweeping through the
European Union because we are not
listening to the people we don't have
the necessary social and environmental
idealism the Antilles Cuba and bits of
the United States have suffered from a
terrible storm we need to fight climate
change the trade deal with Canada flies
in the face of what was agreed in Paris
Europe needs to see social progress
environmental progress in transport
energy housing urban renovation and
farming we need to change the systems of
production that would create thousands
of jobs in Europe
and it would allow new training and
research opportunities all of that is
possible not by setting up a European
Monetary Fund but by turning the Yunker
fund into a real social and
environmental development fund which
through the ECB would write off the
debts of the Member States and kickstart
new projects to protect the lives and
ambitions of all Europeans all that the
Greek government wants is for training
programs for unemployed Greek people to
be funded from the Yunker plan Europe
needs to stop being focused on
competition asocial Europe with a
minimum wage doing away with precarious
work going back to job security proper
pensions eradicating poverty sharing
wealth fairly justice for posted workers
equality between men and women more
rights for people to take decisions in
their companies tax harmonisation
fighting tax fraud and tax havens that's
what we need to be doing enough of this
nauseating discussion of the refugee
crisis let's have a proper Europe of
solidarity let's have a development pact
with Africa and let's root out violence
and war from the Middle East it is high
time to listen to the people
democracy is knocking at the door it's
time to listen and let it in
what we need is a democratic social and
environmental renewal to take place in
Europe starting from the grassroots the
European Union should also help to
reduce conflict it should be in the
vanguard of nuclear disarmament and the
European Union should certainly not beat
a path of militarization as is being
proposed it ought to be promoting
education and culture instead we want to
debate mr. president we want a real
debate which will turn the European
Union into a force of social progress
environmental progress and peace
embedded in democracy any group for now
for the green group the floor goes to
mr. umbehr Chioggia thank you very much
a president mr. Yonker we listen to you
very attentively and I'm trying to put
myself in the shoes of all my citizens
all our citizens that cannot go on like
this anymore that can't make ends meet
that victims of the situation today that
don't aren't covered by Social Security
whereas the richest among our society
get away scot-free so there there's a
lot of problems here they can't they're
not they don't get jobs often there's
more flexibility that is set out but
it's actually more flexibility more
protection for the people that hold the
capital here and also the fight against
terrorism this is something that needs
to be tackled much more they can't go on
as as the stands people are just
suffering too much today a lot of the
time citizens attribute to Europe this
scourge that they can't tolerate anymore
we do have a lot of responsibility
to bear but a lot of the time the
Commission too often doesn't do enough
of course we can congratulate ourselves
and be very pleased that lepen and
wielder and the like don't carry sway
anymore but a lot of citizens aren't
really seeing the benefit of that also
the also nationalistic ideas are also
happening within your political family
mr. young can look at Austria so often
this is called the commission the last
chance Commission but I think there's
more to it than that you need to ensure
that European integration you're trying
to tell citizens that European
integration is in their favor sometimes
they don't understand that message a lot
of the things that you have said are
music to our ears the eurozone proposals
this idea of transnational lists it's
something that we of course go along
with we've been pleading for that for
decades now but everything that you're
suggesting here today is hopefully going
to give us a jolt now that's what we're
hoping for other things that you could
have said today but citizens you might
be legitimately asking yourselves
whether your democracy is actually
working in your favor well what we need
to do is ensure that we reduce
inequalities and ensure that our
ecological pact is being added to our
objective is to give everybody the
possibility of a dignified life how are
we going to achieve that well I am
committed to ensuring that all
legislation all actions all
recommendations coming from my committee
will be screened for these things in
reducing inequalities making sure that
the ecological balance is dect is stuck
to this kind of thing a committee my
committee will not will ensure that
there is cooperation from the bottom
upwards we will ensure that we realign
our
policies it's got to condition the
access to our markets respecting social
stands as environmental standards our
health care standards that we have
chosen also we will freeze SATA the
application of Sita and revise the
recommendations for all the trade
agreements in the offing at the moment
the internal market that needs to be
reworked
we are completely determined on this we
will be deleting glyphosate we will be
wanting to remove glyphosate and also
endocrine disruptors that is something
that we are going to look at very
carefully Europe should be the tool with
which we construct our European future
the only opportunity for Europeans
finding their place in a work world
economy is to ensure that they are at
the vanguard of developments that will
help sustainability on our planet
so rather than defending the current
order our committee my committee will be
supporting anything that goes in that
direction towards that transition we
want a Europe in which nobody feels left
in the cold we need to assume our
responsibilities also these are the
people that are banging on the door
asking for our help we need a more
democratic society the democracy has
been harmed when justice isn't a dared
to and when the universities and media
are undermined there needs to be very
tight checks on this governments need to
ensure that everybody is dealt with in
the same way it shouldn't be giving
succor to the major players that contain
all the capital in their hands no
democracy
is not something that is irreversible we
need to ensure and you have said that
yourself we are the guarantors of the
rule of law we need to ensure that
continues to be the case European Union
is very rich a lot richer and then it
was 60 years ago it's more wealthy in
all kinds of ways but the only way in
which we can take control of our future
is to do this together
mr. Younker implementing this kind of
agenda I think you will have really
grasps your final chance I think you are
somebody that will have put Europe back
on track again rather than being someone
associated with other less favourable
associations and now for the FTD the
first mr. Faraj mr. Yonker that was the
most open honest and truly worrying
speech I've heard in my long years in
this place the message is very clear
brexit has happened
full steam ahead so new plans this to be
one powerful president for the whole of
the European Union a finance minister
with fresh powers - as you say yourself
intervene as of when he sees necessary a
stronger European army in the
militarized European Union with a
stronger and perhaps more aggressive
foreign policy - and more Europe in
every single direction and all of it to
be done without the consent of the
people your plan to fight the next
European elections with cross European
pan-european lists funded by the
European Union but not as you said to
fund extremists means what we will find
is genuine democratic parties of
opposition will not be able to compete
in elections on the same playing field
it is reminiscent of
regimes of old indeed the way you're
treating Hungary and Poland already must
remind them of living under the Soviet
communists when you attempt to tell them
how they should run their own countries
all I can say is thank God we're leaving
but you've learnt you've learned nothing
from brexit if you'd given Cameron
concessions particularly on immigration
the brexit vote I have to admit would
never ever have happened and yet the
lesson you take is you're going to
centralize you're going to move on to
this new I think very worrying
undemocratic Union and you're deluding
yourself mr. behalf stat if you think
that the populist wave as you define it
is over if these plans of mr. Yonkers
come to fruition far from the populist
wave being over I doubt it's even begun
they're a group of robots and now for
the NF group goes to mr. elinsky Thank
You chair ladies and gentlemen we have
to say these are apologists for European
centralism European Union is not Europe
and Europe is not the European Union the
European Union is nothing more than less
than an association an association with
certain rules and you can change these
rules and to change the directions well
we don't agree with it I don't think you
are allowed to make those decisions it's
the people it's the citizen in the free
voting system who are able to make
decisions about the direction and that's
the thing and what mr. Janka said today
goes exactly against that what your car
won't effective is to force the European
Union into a single state and we know
that the euro is not a success story we
extraordinary debts we've seen the
astonishing unemployment we've seen the
astonishing negative social impact on
people's lives we see it's incredible
social instability
the second thing mr. Janka wants is de
facto to actually get rid of the all the
internal borders we see 10,000 hundred
thousands millions of Africans and Arabs
are going to be coming to our continent
everything's going to be there including
terrorists and we know that the people
who committed the terrorist attacks came
through these routes into Europe and
that is a threat to security for all
citizens of our continent they talk
about having a defense a defense Union
but no we don't want that what we want
as Austrians we want we we're neutral
country in Austria what we do not want
to participate in the defense Union the
right Road for Europe can only be the
road where there is more democracy left
to the people more democracy left to the
citizen where people can vote whether or
not they want have
Shaymin maintained or not if they want
to have their borders are not their
votes got to be left to the citizen of
having free movement at a moment of of
terrible unemployment it's the citizen
is got to say whether or not they want
that to be in place that is what we need
in Europe democracy pluralism you have
to give more sovereignty back to the
states if you're never going to function
it doesn't work now and you know it
yourself to be good if we changed it to
act Oakland scenario Park wouldn't the
sixth scenario we heard for the future
of the European Union is yet another
attempt to find a compromise between the
Harz competition that is going on within
the EU and the eurozone were germany has
sprung far ahead from the other
countries at the same time in all
countries all the governments are
pushing ahead with very harsh measures
against the workers in Greece in France
in Italy they're relieving big
businesses from taxes you said some
words about the you becoming more
powerful it only means that the EU is in
class against the United States Japan
and China we cannot hide the fact that
despite your talk about peace the EU is
actively taking part in imperialist Wars
the EU is only becoming worse and the
people's discontent is growing every day
we need to overthrow the real enemy
thing
aura anomaly now in the name of the
council masika's thank you very much
miss president speaking not behalf of
the council the council cannot have a
position on this on this speech speaking
on behalf of thee of the Estonian
presidency of the council I thank
President Juncker for his ambitious
clear and most importantly a thoughtful
speech in this moment with wind in our
sails we should bear in mind a couple of
lessons that in that last couple of
years have taught us first to do we who
care for our union must have the courage
to make the positive case for you it's
not it's not only a right thing to do
but it also may pay off in elections
secondly we should not be afraid of
speaking of the cost of non-eu of the
consequences of so far thank God only
hypothetical rolling back some
advantages of European integration
thirdly we must keep looking for issues
initiatives in ways that unite us and
not those that pose the risk of dividing
Member States we should look for
initiatives that balance things and
build bridges for instance it is much
easier to talk about the EU social
pillar something that the Estonian
presidency will duly take forward when
we simultaneously take real steps in
deepening the single market in
particular in the field of services so
not only better paid jobs but also
better access to these jobs fourthly of
course we must keep developing the EU
further but doing this we must not
forget that this time around in 2017 it
is not the institutional set up that is
most important it is important of course
but
reshaping the institutions must go hand
in hand with providing concrete benefits
concrete things for our citizens our
citizens must be at the center of our
attention delivering concrete benefits
for the citizens that's what the guiding
principle of the Estonian presidency is
ladies and gentlemen for the last
several years we have all been working
on building a digital single market the
free movement of data is one of its
cornerstones we need to ensure that
European citizens and businesses are
able to benefit from data and that we
create no new barriers to the single
market as with the --use other freedoms
free movement does not mean a freedom
from rules next year new EU personal
data protection rules come into force
and we look forward to starting work on
the Commission's new proposal on the
free flow of data Thank You president
Juncker for this proposal member states
have repeatedly emphasized that
legislation in this area is necessary
the Estonian presidency will move now
swiftly attempting to consolidate member
states positions on the concrete
proposal as we grow Europe's data
economy and enter the era of the
Internet of Things cybersecurity becomes
a matter for everyone we welcome the
renewal of the EU cybersecurity strategy
proposed by the Commission cybersecurity
is a challenge that cannot be tackled by
any member state on the road we all need
to fulfill our responsibilities by fully
implementing the existing EU legislation
must deploy all parts of our toolbox
working on the new legislation working
engaging with the private sector the EU
also has an important role to play
setting international norms pursuing
cyber criminals standing up for European
values such as freedom and privacy
guiding the development of the global
market for secure products and services
and reacting to states that sponsor and
support malicious cyber activity
the ears heads of state and government
will address these key issues at the
telling digital summit 29th of September
ladies and gentlemen I only listed some
recent lessons for the EU we have also
learned that while strengthening the EU
internally is of course key for the
health and functioning of the Union
itself at the same time to be and to
appear strong the EU also needs to
remain engaged and open to the outside
world we are a model to a number of
countries in our neighbourhood and we
should not forget it the EU s
transformative power is still very much
there the Eastern Partnership summit in
November is an opportunity to reconfirm
our commitment to our neighbours
positive transformation in the field of
trade the EU must perform a tough
balancing act president Juncker laid out
very eloquently the elements of it we of
course welcome the message that we can
now proceed with the free trade
agreements with Australia in New Zealand
and to expand the network of liberal
trade relations in this globalized world
the Commission has gone a long path with
its reflection paper on harnessing
globalization and deserves to be
commended for that with regard to the
proposals about investments and the
multilateral investment court as
presidency we will make our best efforts
to proceed in the best possible way to
build the consensus among the Member
States in a manner that will enable the
EU to continue its leading role in trade
policy and now to migration the crisis
of which shook the fundamentals of the
EU and showed that the EU does not
really have a headquarters to manage an
acute operational crisis bu doesn't have
a general if you will this is not to say
that we haven't had achieved a lot in
the field of migration the work on the
external dimension is ongoing
well and maybe for the first time the
Union is using all the tools in
foreign policy toolbox at the same time
assistant development trade military
operation enlargement policy even the
Estonian presidency is working hard on
migration issues not least while
carrying forward work with a common
Asylum system on legal migration we
eagerly eagerly started working with the
European Parliament on the blue card
directive on security we are ready to
engage with the Parliament on atheists
and hopefully on these initiatives and
of course we are confident that an
inclusive and ambitious permanent
structured cooperation in the field of
defence can be lodged launched by the
end of this year ladies and gentlemen
the speech by President Lincoln and the
debate we have had so far shows us once
more that you know in in our union there
is much more of what unites us than what
creates tensions Estonia a country that
was deprived of the advantages of the
European integration during its first 40
years feels that particularly deeply
that is the compass while we act as a
Member State that is our compass
especially while we are performing the
duties of the presidency of the Council
of the EU with the wind in our sails
thank you
[Applause]
beasty Dimpy now because of the time
restraints were not going to have any
blue cards here the focus mr. Caspari
secure president mr. president one or
two years ago the mood here was Samba
Commission President Juncker talked
about a window of opportunity and we
should seize that opportunity
Manfred Weber talked about people's or
worries worries for instance about
globalization give us some weeks to talk
to these citizens what we need to see is
quick transparent negotiations with
Australia and New Zealand we need to
protect our we need to reform our trade
protection instruments and an instrument
again against external strategic
investment because we need to be able to
protect our industrial base secondly
people are worried about jobs not least
Germans about jobs in the car industry
there's a crisis of trust but we also as
we take climate action we need to
protect jobs because we need climate
protection we need cars and we need jobs
we don't we can't have one and lose the
others and this is what has to permeate
our legislative proposals in the coming
months and on the transnational lists
many people think that we're in an ivory
tower here in Europe we need to bridge
the gap we need to we need to be closer
to the citizens pan-european lists in my
view will set us further apart from
citizens and therefore we reject them oh
no they were literally wish no man with
Regas
welcome mr. president this is a moment
for us as a last shot to have a real
vision and ambition what is at stake for
this legislature
it is indeed to develop the European
House and to move to the next stage a
new floor is to make Europe not only as
a single market or a eurozone but also
as a political entity able to respond to
the new world in front of us we need a
repeat union as a big democratic power
supporting our way of life and making
sure that we have the means to deliver
our values and our way of life these
means indeed to have new means for peace
and security to manage migration and to
support development but for these we do
need a new brand new community budget
for the future based on new own
resources turned to the future not to
the past and this means when it comes on
resources that big corporations should
pay their taxes because they must
benefit from the single market but pay
what they do to pay then if we have in
mind a new democratic political entity
this can only be based on stronger
european citizenship first of all
respecting fully the fundamental
political rights of our citizens but
also making sure that we can count on
updated social standards when it comes
access to social protection when it
comes access to skills but also making
sure that every
in employment whatever the kind of jobs
they have they can count on the decent
labor contract and this access to Social
Protection this should be the ambition
of the upcoming European social pillar
but can we say that these Europe as land
of equal opportunity of fairness is
being delivered to all European citizens
we don't think so Europe is still
working as a machinery for diversions
and inequality and we need to reverse
these very undermining trend so we call
upon the Commission to come up with an
ambitious proposal of community European
budget turning European project a
project for equality and conversions and
these should apply for the European
Union as a whole and also for DeRose own
so this is our request for the upcoming
work coming from the European Commission
the presbytery
people to please stick to the time
that's been given to you because
otherwise we will end up cutting time
from other any piece you wish to but has
bitten catch the eye the floor now goes
to mr. Lucca hey mr. Janka you had 60
minutes to build illusions castles in
the air' you've awakened illusions that
really have no realistic basis that
don't really tackle the problems that
the European Union is facing you talked
about the reality of the European Union
and you talked about fish fingers
vaccinations cocoa content of chocolate
but what about the major problems that
need to be tackled in the European Union
you haven't offered any solutions you
talked about the law of the rule of law
but you didn't talk about the breach of
the Maastricht Treaty that the fiscal
pact has been infringed several times
the double impact that all of these
things
have been violated that monetary estate
funding is still being carried out these
illusions you are giving succor to them
220 billion euros that have been
generated but the banks are saying
there's not actually any project that we
wouldn't have funded anyway so you're
not addressing Europe's real problems
and the European Union will not get out
of the crisis in this manner Thank You
president Kerr not bad in fact not bad
at all I think that this is something
that I can very well work with on the
cheque domestic political scene we are
spoken about your life having been a
fighter
of course me on a different level I've
been going through a similar experience
in the Czech Republic and I think that
with this vision with these ideas I mean
I'm happy to confront some of your
former counterparts politicians that
have use of the first half of 20th
century so thanks for that
even though of course some disagreements
say for sure but that is absolutely
normal
let's forget the five scenarios I think
that we we both know that three of them
were no scenarios at all and I think
that if we have now the priority agenda
I will have wished may be that you have
shortly sit two three more but I
understand that we will find them in in
the report but I think that the
implementation of these priorities the
reform agenda that you have put emphasis
on and that I subscribe to will lead us
to the outcome and that is the sixth
scenario so the European Union that we
want to have maybe someone will fall
behind but today of course remains to be
seen
finally mark unity I I believe as you do
that we are in a better shape but if we
have still a problem that is lack of
unity in the council lack of ability of
the Member States to deliver on what
they have even proclaimed themselves
before one final remark president uncle
I'm not offended that you have forgotten
the Czech Republic as a country that
will also be 100 years old nest next
year no offense thank you
whenever they can no mr. karti Thank You
chair I must admit I find it arrogant
mr. president that you say that things
are going in the right direction because
that's not the view of our citizens they
see poverty they see deterioration of
their welfare they see their salaries
under pressure they see high on
unemployment particularly youth
unemployment and they see an EU that
doesn't solve their problems but makes
their problems worse they see an EU that
does not listen to them but instead of
looking at the real problems you sit
there with the rest of the EU elite in
your glass tower saying you want more EU
more power to the EU Commission a
finance minister to control the Member
States even more in the direction of the
Commission a president or for all
presidents to make sure we have one
union with one president I find it
arrogant towards our citizens and
towards our democracy and honestly I
think that this Commission has plenty of
powers already I'm going to talk to you
today in Spanish surprisingly you didn't
mention the situation in Spain with the
upcoming Catalonian referendum because
hundreds and thousands of Qatar lands
have been asking for a referendum on
auto-determination just like the
Scottish the government never wants to
speak about this I hear about it the
Catalan government has approved by
majority the law of the referendum as if
it were in fact a crime to have
referendum a court case has been brought
against the president of the Catalan
Parliament and also against over over a
thousand local civil servants who are
working in favor of the referendum these
are unacceptable attacks on freedom of
opinion
I'm not asking that you actually fight
for independence the Catlins can do it
on their own but I do ask that you
actually require that the Spanish come
to an agreement on the referendum why
does the Commission not intervene in
order to defend the freedom of
expression in Spain you do it in other
countries would you not thank you very
much full steam ahead yeah thank you
full steam ahead is what we've heard see
it reminds me of the Titanic that film
that scene where the captain stands on
the bridge looks at the Seas looks at
the oceans and doesn't see an iceberg
and says right full steam ahead we all
know what the fate of the Titanic was no
people in Europe aren't really
interested in this kind of vision anyway
you know in these visions that you've
set out mr. Yonko they want tangible
solutions to they're very tangible
problems on a day-to-day basis but you
don't seem to manage to do this social
dumping is one example and the future of
our young people as well those are the
kind of things that citizens want
responses to but they have just remained
vague visions and dreams more Europe
more federalization is what you seem to
be pleading for but really it's the
other side of things that we need to
talk about in the next few years mr. by
mr. Yonker this Parliament has still
ridiculous as it was last July for you
we already know the lack of respect that
you have for the people of Europe and
now you showed that day in fact the
content that you also have for the
representatives you don't just actually
have contempt for the MEP but also for
the heads of state and government or
hungary poland and slovakia who stand up
against your ideas miss you
you said a moment ago that Europe is a
an ageing continent you said you wanted
to set up some new roads for extra
European immigration even though that in
fact is what caused a profound identity
security economic and social disorders
that were dealing with you try to
actually distinguish legal immigration
which you want to encourage from
clandestine immigration which you want
to fight without ever giving yourselves
the resources now these two kinds of
immigration don't catch each other they
accumulate we have to give hope and
confidence that people of Europe we have
to get their own demographic the
dynamism you have to give them the
mastery of their own destiny and build a
Europe which is built on cooperation
that's our vision that's against your
vision use a federalist rigid and
totalitarian laugh at all mr. Simon
board president and president colleagues
probably more presidents here than
colleagues at the moment but never never
mind in the last three years as an MEP I
have achieved a great deal of work I
sent away the Brits I D throned mr.
Schultz and I also ensured that Helmut
Kohl was re somewhere else and also
there's the Polish pis party I've tried
to teach them democratic values and I'm
particularly proud that the EU has taken
onboard an original idea that we had
normally a wall a wall around Europe
just recently going along with the CSU
we asked for an upper limit of for
refugees Germany shouldn't take in more
every year than the Mediterranean ocean
now the Mediterranean Mediterranean
ocean is is full so the idea is to
construct a wall around those failed
States Chad and Molly and I would like
to say sorry to very to foreigners here
because a lot of decisions were deferred
until after the
in Germany just another week and then
the party will start governing again mr.
Weber you have a point of order so good
if our president in this entire
Parliament Madam President this is a
parliament where we have freedom of
speech and everybody is entitled to say
what they want however to speak of the
deceased as mr. Sano born just has in
the case of Helmut Kohl that is a matter
for the Bureau to deal with it is
completely undignified and unacceptable
Thank You mr. Weber we will look into
that matter I now give the floor for one
and a half minutes to mr. levin dosti
seguir thank you there's a different
climate in Europe now we had a very
different State of the Union speech in
2017 this was not technocratic optimism
last year we were shocked by the UK
referendum we thought that there would
be a rising tide of populism instead of
shock though now we have shock therapy
and it's not Europe that's in the shadow
of brexit it's the United Kingdom the
greater creation of the founding fathers
is going to continue to flourish
we have scenario number six this is good
news there are some exceptions to the
good news though my country Poland is
also going to be celebrating a hundred
years of regaining independence my
country Poland is inhabited by people
who feel good in Europe and about Europe
they feel themselves at home in Europe
I'd like to say on behalf of my
delegation that we'll do everything we
can to ensure that Poland will be a full
participant in the quest for a new
European you
thank you thank you madam fie on one
minute please
while I put it's a dual charm shiny but
it's scenic you encouraged us to eat
together
Thank You president I would like to
congratulate you on your speech
president Younker rule of law
young people and the Western Balkan area
these three things are very much close
to my heart you talked about the rule of
law and you said that Court judges
should be enforced you talked about you
know countries shouldn't be able to
decide themselves which judgments they
enforce or carry out or not what about
some countries that aren't doing this
you need to look at that mr. Janka and
then how do young people get any faith
in the European Union they see
politicians not really responding to
their problems they are unemployed they
don't get jobs and the Western Balkan
area there are problems you said you
wanted a credible enlargement policy but
that's not happening because it's a
playground for geopolitical interests
we're going to have second-class
citizens if we're not careful we need to
invest in Europe that is not a continent
of intolerance hate and walls my biggest
wish is to ensure that we can breathe
fully thank you mr. urban Crespo is
likely seized ladies and gentlemen the
crisis in Europe started in 2008 mr.
young Co you will finish your job in
2019 and this in fact will be seen
history as a last decade it'll be a
decade of austerity in Europe the
European Union is not in fact moving
forward it's not a problem of speed it's
actually a problem of political well
with your speech you insist on
continuing on the same road that has
brought us to this situation
it's a federalist vision what you're
doing is you are creating an
the Democratic machine which in fact
leads to blackmail financial blackmail
in order to impose a neoliberal vision
not as already proved it doesn't work
and which ends up falling on the
shoulders of the European population the
problems in Europe aren't going to be
solved by new trade associations more
externalization of our borders isn't
going to help more budgets for defense
isn't going to help this is going to
lead to more austerity because these are
responding to the interests of
multinationals lobbies and government
what we need is a change of direction we
want a hundred and eighty degree change
of the external policy ecological policy
of a mental policy and social policy
that's we have to do we have to work
from the ground up this would be a real
change I'm following the instructions of
the president who really asked us to
respect our speaking time one minute now
for mr. Vallee please see Grazia
president thank you very much madam
president
mr. young Kerr touched on very important
topics security immigration economic
mass aspects I'd like to focus on
economic aspects the European Stability
Mechanism and front turning that into a
European fund is something that's quite
difficult to understand for some people
I think it's quite easy particularly
with regard to what the European finance
minister has suggested namely a
structure namely the troika it would
mean that member states would give money
to the to the ESM and would receive in
ribbon against that they would receive
reforms that's the idea that that as a
counter they would receive restore
reforms but I'm not sure that will
really work there's the quantitative
easing idea that has also been put
forward but we've got Germany that isn't
assuming its responsibility is it's not
accepting true euro bonds or fiscal
transfers so that's all these structural
in democratic
problems that will continue to support
intolerance and sufferance and this is
completely unacceptable
thank you mrs. Atkinson one minute
pleased that you think everything in the
EU garden is rosy there's no mention of
the 50,000 jihad is waiting to blow us
up that going through your failed
immigration policies no mention of your
failed immigration policies and the
marauding migrants breaking into our
countries at least the European Eastern
European countries have got the right
idea no mention of your failed youth
employment schemes but there is good
news in the UK we have record employment
despite brexit we've got record inward
investment despite rate set volume of
output is the highest in 20 years
despite brexit and Bill Gates said that
despite breaks that Britain still can
lead in a science and tech nology
institutes and our older books are the
highest in 30 years
despite brexit the City of London is
still number one despite Rexxar so sorry
to invade your space mr. Younker but you
and the EU and your ideas are really
past their sell-by date mish approached
one and a half minutes but should
because you don't
mr. president all too often we week has
in the case of our reaction to the court
judgment on Singapore or the failure of
multilateralism the fact is we've now
seen a new development in globalization
economic planning by foreign powers
dumping hostile investments the
acquisition of strategic companies
strict rules on our companies operating
abroad unfair competition and the lack
of reciprocity there was no agreement
yesterday in the trial log on dumping I
don't think this is a failure because we
need to have a clear political message
especially as regards the burden of
proof Europe needs to protect itself
without lapsing into protectionism
that's a clear message our treaty
requires us to be extremely cautious in
terms of our legal obligations hence the
uncertainty the ambitious draft
regulation will at least save us walking
on our heads we've lost time and in
reality we're losing jobs we're losing
know-how and technological advancement
as a result of country that's organizing
its investments and private and public
companies we're not against foreign
investment but we're against strange
investment we need to make sure that we
don't end up with future apples or
iPhones assembled entirely in China now
see one minute mr. stanishev
thank you madam chair and thank you
president Juncker for your speech I know
you are deeply convinced European and in
your sixth scenario I don't see Europe
which is divided or several speedy
Europe which is very positive but at the
same time you know that people are tired
of words and promises and it's time for
action from the Commission as well and
the strongest tool which you possess as
a commission is the project the draft of
your budget for the next multi-annual
financial framework
we should stop thinking how to reduce
the European budget but look but look
for own resources we should really focus
on political priorities and the major
priority is how to move from Europe of
divergence inequalities towards Europe
of convergence and strong economic
growth and social justice I expected
frankly speaking stronger social
dimension we really need a European
social action plan today in order to
regain trust thank you very much one and
a half minutes mr. Gonzalez pons vientos
favorably Senor
well favorable winds that's true mr.
young we've left behind the euro crisis
and now we've got to also move this
positive atmosphere onto social
protection and works I liked what you
said about the rule of law and equality
sometimes it seems in Europe that is
more important to us to solve the
financial crisis than the political and
social crisis that we face here we
talked about brexit as if it were just
you know going to be another free trade
association actually starting from this
it isn't just about European Union
defending the idea of Europe what we've
got to do after brexit we have to see
that the will in fact be do different
Europe's inside our continent I share
your points of view when it comes to the
role of Courts as regard the European
Court and national courts this is in
fact one of the very finding reasons of
the European Union there are countries
that are attacking the separation of
power and that's what's happening in a
region in fact in my country where
nationalism is not attacking the
Constitution nationalism is expanding
just like a virus the constitution of
each member state is in fact the
building blocks of the European Union
the unity of my country is also the
unity of the European Union this is why
the European Commission has also got and
I share this responsibility to defend
the Constitution's of all of the Member
States and to defend the unity of the
Member State and the rule of law is born
out of the individual right
but it grows and developed if you follow
the law and the courts thank you
thank you one minute madam Tama thank
you very much I'm very disappointed I
have to say first of all your last
chance saloon hasn't really worked
you're not giving us a battle plan for
the end of the mandate you're giving us
a strange way ahead strange route ahead
for the future
there are a certain number of priorities
that we could go along with social tax
and public freedom but these are all
words moving from words to deeds as you
said this morning we need a serious
budget and that's my second
disappointment you're saying you want to
break out of this straitjacket that
exists now but what about this 20%
ceiling nothing definite about that own
resources nothing about that
multinational taxes nothing there either
fiscal justice is something that we
really need to focus on and that hasn't
happened so I'm very disappointed as
well about economic and monetary
democracy there are new prerogatives
that we want what we need is to ensure
that we can choose economic ways forward
and break out of austerity but you
haven't given us the chance to do that
thank you madam Gardini one minute
please
cigarette tip therapist thanks madam
president mr. president you've set out a
model for the future of Europe and I can
share a lot of the things you've said
starting with the protection of Europe's
strategic interest some analysts think
that this is the most important
geopolitical aspect of your whole speech
I want to say something about the reform
of the Treaty of Dublin that's a
priority for our group and
it's unavoidable if we want to back
European industry starting with small
and medium enterprises youth
unemployment but let me just say one
question in my brief remaining time
Europe needs more democracy you've said
but you didn't say anything about that
this assembly directly elected elected
by our citizens doesn't have a
legislative initiative rights don't you
think that should be on the agenda we
need to get the wind in our sails as
you've said and we can do that if
citizens really see it that they at the
heart of everything we do in Europe
thank you president thank you one minute
madam Garcia Perez that's it thank you
mister madam president
four years now Europe has stopped being
part and parcel of our dreams and the
idea of a project which is equality
opportunities has become something
altogether different precarious jobs
austerity economic crisis today those of
us who believe in the European project
will agree that there are grounds for
concern that we need to move ahead with
new policies for the European Union the
European social pillar must be a
priority it's simply not possible for a
21st century Europe to continue to have
a working class that lives below the
poverty line let's talk about the fight
against climate change let's face up to
the fight against terrorism asylum and
immigration policy these are fundamental
importance Thank You mr. Janka for
mentioning the rule of law Europe is a
project based on democracy therefore
it's fundamental that we guarantee a
respectful the constitutional order of
each and every member state there's no
time to be wasted we need to get on with
it and tackle these changes diversity
dialogue respect cohesion this is what
defines Europe let's not allow anything
or anybody changes this thank you
one minute mr. sugar hey most welcome
with emphasis you place on the idea of
Europe the community of values mr.
Rinker that the need to ensure freedom
equality and rule of law all over the
you said that we there would no be
second-class citizens anymore in our
integration project still European
citizens belonging to national adopt
honest or language minorities can be
treated very differently depending on
where they live only last week in
Romania Hungarian minority language
Catholic High School of tilbury ceased
to exist because the systematic
harassment of various authorities were
hundreds of minority language speaking
children were in security until the last
moment about whether they would be able
to attend their school again what do the
parents of these children who are
interrogated by the Romanian
anti-corruption agency for enrolling
their children in the school feel from
the rule of law that the you is supposed
to guarantee them the you still has a
long way to go to ensure its values and
prevent discriminative practices more
than 60 million citizens expect
acknowledgement of their existence by
the institutions thank you mr. Biden
holds our one minute Dean William king
Vatican II at the moment we're in a
curious situation in Europe we've got
Trump and got brexit but thanks to that
people are more positive about the EU
but it's not all good we're a long way
from having solved the migration issue
and the improvement in the economy that
you have mentioned isn't benefiting
everybody parts of Austria for example
aren't seeing that and there's also more
of a disparity now between East and West
you know I'm happy to see mr. timmermans
here taking a very clear clear line the
Commission is the custodian of the
treaties and has to guarantee the
fundamental rights as a result but it's
this openness to dialogue that I'm not
seeing in those who
trying to benefit at the expense of
Brussels how to act against that well
Brussels has to be better more
democratic and act in a more social way
and I think you've given us a good basis
for that madam phalion one minute Thank
You president congratulations for your
strong messages in your State of the
Union today for the first time in years
or citizens show growing faith in the
you and its direction their confidence
is just a fine proof that the EU remains
where they put their hopes and where
they want to live and prosper for all
these we are ibly obliged to keep our
word and deliver on what we have
promised some will say we'll need more
ambition I say we need stability
consolidation and proper implementation
of your policies we need to defend our
values to make sure citizens can fully
benefit from their rights and freedoms
and the other competitiveness of our
companies is both defended and supported
yet the engine of our internal market is
not fairness but competition and it has
to be a real one you can't send people
home saying go compete in your own
country while we protect our national
markets because the internal market it's
not the sum of national markets the
state of the union should also be about
how we can offer more Europe for
everyone thank you thank you madam
Moscow one minute
great simplicity thank you madam
president president Juncker
trade policy is one of the most powerful
instruments we have and although
obviously it can't sort out everything
it needs to be continually updated and
improved to meet global challenges which
are constantly in flux
I was listening carefully to what you
were saying particularly about
transparency but I think we should
really stress three points first of all
trade is still genuinely European policy
open Democratic without sacrificing the
need for us to pull together
that's why the union needs to be ever
more closely involved in all phases of
the process and not simply Parliament's
a sense at the end of an agreement being
reached secondly sustainable development
if the chapters on that are going to be
effective they need to be binding
I'm glad the Commission's done what it's
done but it needs to continue thinking
bring it into real practice and
providing sufficient money and
Parliament's willing to help on that
thirdly it's vital because opening up in
terms of trade is based on fairness and
reciprocity and we can't have these
waivers depending on who the partner is
that will threaten our whole economic
system thank you madam president mr. Ron
Schell one minute Carol madam vice
president
mr. Yonko my dear president first of all
my compliments to you full today speech
thank you I think this gives a new
Philip to us it encouraged all of us who
- all of us who love Europe like mr.
Yonker now there is a challenge which is
not one of your immediate concerns at
least not those we heard today this year
there was a wave of forest fires in
Portugal with tragic consequences have
been floods all over Europe including
recently impotant but tragic consequence
it last year there were earthquakes in
Italy they've also been earthquakes in
Greece and with climate change are going
to be a lot of these catastrophes would
it not be time to create a year European
civil protection force now this of
course ties in with internal security
that have missions in the Mediterranean
rescue at sea this kind of thing but
when this kind of catastrophe supervenes
we should get out there help national
forces to mitigate the consequences of
such catastrophes I think it's high time
to create a European civil protection
force and it would be the Emperor of
what could eventually become a real
European army thank you
mr. Pohlman one minute guarantee Uncas
yob president Janka
you've given a speech which meets up to
your own expectations
it was sober and we've heard that the
East we needs the West but also vice
versa and I think the same goes for
north and south as well I've never been
quite as revolted as the time when I had
to read in the German papers saying if
you want coal Seles Corfu I mean this
was quoted from stupid politicians and
I'm very glad that you never got dragged
into that debate but you stood up to it
I know that that's not the level at
which you operate but we can't say that
economic policy in Europe depends on
who's in government where whether
there's a Greek haircut is a technical
issue it shouldn't depend on whether or
not your political allies are in
government in one country or not we need
a policy that can help the south to
develop but we need the south in this
very difficult period the world's going
through mr. kovachev 1-minute reversal
thank you madam president
I'm pleased with what you've told us mr.
president now we need to achieve the
goals that you've said we need to be
effective in the European Union because
it'll be our fault if the European Union
is ineffective next year the EU needs to
demonstrate that the promise is to keep
its citizens safe going to be met we
should focus therefore on things like
cyber security control of our X term
borders and solidarity to be shown with
states where there are a large number of
migrants entering I like the idea of a
cybersecurity agency mr. president we
also need to continue to help Europe
recover economically and maintain its
social standards and its public health
standards and also we need to help those
sectors where the crisis as his us
hardest and we shouldn't allow any part
of the European Union to be neglected
I'm glad that you're thinking about we
not have a two-speed Europe that's the
most important thing Thank You mr. Naro
thank you madam president don't
appreciate interim president jean-claude
Juncker I would like to thank you today
for the courage the vision and the
wisdom of your speech but moreover for
the force to oppose those who favor eyes
the division of Europe and the double
standards in the project of Europe with
several speeds on behalf of the Romanian
delegation on behalf of my political
group and on behalf of my country I
share your vision and I commit myself to
supporting you if I analyze your speech
Europe can be an important player in
matters of security only if we are
united
only if we speak on one voice and only
if there is complete trust among all
members if we look at the cohesion
policy it is fundamental to implement
the principle of solidarity and to
reduce all these parities and this is
why I would like you to give attention
to come to the continuation of this
fundamental instrument of the Union
Union and solidarity means that there
are no double standards in cases of
enhanced cooperation that Schengen
cannot be refused when there are
conditions which are fulfilled and that
the CBM cannot be continued unless it is
necessary and the quality of food is
this
for all Europeans Thank You mr. Needham
our one minute please
Thank You Madame and thank you mr.
president for your speech
it is good to remind us about how things
have changed since last year just to
remind all of us grosses up unemployment
down employment up stable financial
sector improved fiscal policy and this
is just economy you mentioned more you
can say these are just numbers these are
not just numbers
this means that life for people in
Europe is better and this is what people
expect from us also as you know from
your past a good time is exactly the
time where people are making a lot of
mistakes and you urge us to not make
mistakes in this good time and instead
two good many good things and I agree
and I appreciated it one of the
obstacles that I want to stress is still
missing trust trust among politicians
trust among people trust among countries
I hope that in next speech you will
remind us that this has improved this is
very important and also at the end of
your speeches you mentioned that we
shouldn't be over cautious this is
exactly the way how to make the mistakes
and to miss the opportunities I hope we
will not miss them thank you very much
thank you
one minute madam Van Brunt thank you all
for seaters committee four-seater
yonkers thank you very much mr.
president of the Commission your speech
was optimistic perhaps not fully fledged
optimism was expressed but the general
turn was optimistic and it's something I
think we can support with a fair degree
of enthusiasm transparency climate
protection the climate of Industry
ensuring that there's more democracy we
completely agree however we were still
left feeling that there could have been
we want a triple-a on social issues
three years issue three is discussion on
social dumping and results look we need
to ensure that everybody in Europe
to work in the same conditions and
receive the same salary there's got to
be proper social security in Shanthi
European legislation and and will be
measured on our action particular on
social action thank you thank you Madame
oles cook one minute please to tone man
[Music]
madam president mr. president of the
Commission thank you for what you've
told us this morning mr. Juncker and
thank you for having talked about better
standards for the labor market these
better standards will be crucial for the
whole of the EU we need to take positive
measures here nothing divides us more
than social dumping which means that
workers are set against workers and sell
their labor as cheaply as possible
that's a disgrace for Europe and there
are many of us who are focusing our
hopes on you to improve the situation we
need to have some kind of overseeing
authority but also legislation a
directive and legislation on the social
market that can't be done the labor
market sorry that can't be done from
outside we need a social protocol thank
you as you said on the eurozone we think
you need to respect countries which
don't want to take part such as my own
that needs to be respected that decision
thank you president thanks we now move
to catch the eye and I will disappoint
more people than I will please so with
that remark I will try and give the
floor to as many as possible but
probably around nine colleagues so
immediately for one minute and very
strictly please madam spear Aki thank
you madam president president Janka the
citizens are waiting for us directly to
show we don't like populism
and extremism in Europe we need to come
up with rational correct solutions we
can't
it seems provide wellbeing for everybody
we need to make sure however that we
encourage our citizens and reward as
many of them as we can we need to keep
Europe safe from terrorism and we need
to have a European information service
which will help that goal we have large
numbers of migrants and member states
need to look to their own
responsibilities here and need to be
sanctioned if they don't the Greeks and
the Italians are facing the brunt of
this crisis mr. president and we need to
make sure that cuts in the budget for
things like research don't hamper the
situation still further Thank You
signora procedure madam president
president young come in there in your
home straight you've given us your
longer speech with the most intentions
we want actual solutions that legal ways
in not just this blue card for selective
immigration we want humanitarian visas
visas decent jobs for young people fight
against poverty particularly child
poverty fight against inequality
tackling fraud and tax havens we've seen
all of this in a pen of our committee
all but above at the Earth Day it's not
about rule of law ignoring Court rulings
is being in breach of the law it's a
crime and that can happen in Hungary in
Poland and Catalonia anywhere it's a
negation of Europe we're about the rule
of law thank you one minute mr. Mariusz
thank you madam president president
Yunker your five scenarios the change in
the European Union in their put forward
a sixth one which where we continue with
the same policies the same institutions
and the same
is that existed before a German
dominated Europe austerity and the
stability pact
it's the anti-democratic eurozone the
uncontrolled euro groove running the
European and the European Central Bank
its Bangkok recei and the series of
people friendly measures are being
brought in outsourcing and we can see
Europe's industrial base being
undermined and European salaries being
reduced so Europe of unemployment and
marginalization of young people and this
of course had been worsened by a million
migrants and illegal migrants what we
need to do is combat unemployment and
poverty and we can't do it by failing to
deal with the huge migrant flows which
are existing at the moment we need to do
something to protect the European family
thank you may only be barber and DCAM
miss Bilbao bar Anika senior young care
come up with it mr. Juncker as you can
see here my party the P&V
organized or celebrated the national
past day in 1932 saying Basque Country
Europe so I liked a lot of proposals but
what about women who suffer inequality
of violence we need need proper support
for plants and we need to protect and
empower people we want a social Europe
that's open refuge united against
terrorism more industry support for the
real economy economic and political
capacity the single energy and digital
market we are victims of the short
sessom member states democratic values
the rights of everybody including
national minorities that do exist and as
in Catalonia instead of recognizing that
reality you prefer to just stifle
everything without political action
dialogue we have a European problem
the intergroup on minorities in this
Parliament has called for dialogue
democracy gonna be imposed but nobody
should hinder it either nobody should
hinder a political solution to this
problem I'm are they well they're City
Quixote's mr. city Quixote's Thank You
mr. president the Union today needs to
remain stable and at the surface of its
citizens we need to make sure that there
are plans to increase unemployment and
improve labor conditions particularly in
those countries which are living under
memoranda but you're just offering the
same thing again keeping the regional
imbalances and unfairness is in place
mr. president
we still have poverty pockets in Europe
what we need to do is not submit money
willy-nilly in the defense fund we need
to make sure that there's real economic
growth on Europe we need to make sure
that there be some proper way of dealing
with the refugees not simply some
agreement put together with Turkey we in
the left want to see a different kind of
Europe getting rid of poverty and
inequality we need more public
expenditure if we are going to create
decent jobs we need a social Europe a
Europe of solidarity and peace we need a
Europe in the interest of its citizens
thank you there's a lunatic president of
the Commission the Greens slogan about
EU is remain critical but remain we want
to make a environmentally sustainable at
Union so that citizens can believe in it
again
cosmetic changes are simply not enough
you've made a few interesting
suggestions but when it comes to trade
it's still the interests of the big
companies that are being put to the
fourth the balance is not as it should
be in a democracy what we want what we
need are fair trade agreements otherwise
there's no point in talking about why
refugees flee their homes what you said
about the rule of law was good to hear
and I also is pleased to hear you say
that you together with the European
Parliament will be looking at the
funding of European parties and
foundations and to change that funding
so that right-wing extremists can't fill
their coffers in order to knock back the
European principals but it's not enough
to describe the State of the Union we
have to change the imbalance and make
the EU credible again for all EU
citizens there's more of a thank you
very much
mr. Uecker in your position I think it's
a very good idea to watch television
every now and then if you do so these
days you can see really good news from
Syria and from Iraq the wars are almost
over rebuilding has begun refugees are
returning home don't you think and
please answer this question don't you
think that it's high time to
fundamentally we consider the relocation
and resettlement quota idea of the
European Union stop bashing Hungary stop
preaching us about solidarity and talk
about solidarity to those strong healthy
young Syrian and other men who should go
home and rebuild their countries that is
solidarity with those nations thank you
very much Christopher Oh mr. Christopher
oh dear oppressor
Thank You president I welcome the speech
of the president of the Commission and
and particularly pleased that he focused
on the core values of the European Union
we need to look at freedom the rule of
law and equality mr. president that is
what Europe is based on and that's what
the basis for a strong Europe giving
well-being to its citizens and we
shouldn't have agreements with countries
like Turkey who don't share our European
values European citizens should feel
proud when they take part in the
freedoms which Europe has given them and
don't forget we couldn't deal with
countries which don't simply fail to
respect human rights at home but have
seized territory in my own country it's
important that we remember this and
don't simply allow the customs union to
continue in the way that it is at the
moment we have values in Europe and we
need to protect them together mr.
president thank you well it costs that
miss Costa Presidente UK gracias Thank
You mr. president president Janka thank
you for what you've said and you're
genuinely European vision it's something
which could put the wind in the sails of
Europe again and help young citizens
particularly young British citizens who
are going to be suffering the impact of
BRICS is when we need to look at
sustainable development defense foreign
policy more justice we can play a role
in the world and that can only be
guaranteed by more Europe free fair
United United also in terms of the
priorities that it has and the values
which it shares if we're going to do
that we need to have a culture or an
educational dimension of the European
project they need to be leading elements
on 30 years on from the beginning of
Erasmus let me ask you whether we can't
think about doubling the number of young
people who are eligible that's still
only 5% of young you
that would of course recall the doubling
of its budget the European cultural
heritage day yeah which you mentioned
that's going to begin in Milan in
December along with our new cultural
diplomacy most mogherini and
commissioned elaborate issue behind that
that's a tremendous opportunity for us
to share and disseminate our values and
promote intercultural dialogue and
developing Europe's social cohesion
creating quality jobs thank you very
much this mecha
thank you for seated Mineo Thank You mr.
president
mr. Janka well we keep on talking about
a democratic Europe about recovering
their hearts and minds of our citizens
the trust of citizens and the fact of
matter is any peace we are close to our
citizens after all that's how democracy
begins and works and I have to say to
our group with what the Catalan
colleague said last week hundreds of
thousands of Catalans filled the streets
of Barcelona with color and I think we
needed to develop their European future
we've got to do that democratically and
we know full well that the problems
between positive Madrid have gone to
court and that civil servants have been
given orders to boycott the referendum
there has been intimidation in the media
and elsewhere you're aware of that and
as a Fleming we can't accept that one to
Europe as citizens and we want the
democracy to flourish and be respected
it is mr. Gandhi's last speaker in catch
the I thank you president president
Yunker the situation in Europe isn't
really as you described it workers look
at the Union as something which is
reducing their wages and rights
pensioners say nothing but further cuts
in their pensions unemployed people see
the carrot plus in terms of investment
but the stick of the weakening of legal
protection and threat of job losses your
comments and what mr. macro said
recently show that you're violating
democracy particularly in my own country
you're ignoring the wishes of the Greek
people expressed in 2015 and your
Commissioner has said that the Greeks
trying to end austerity in their own
country as a scandal this is simply not
fair we need to work together in terms
of the industry and the environment but
we need a Europe of peace not simply a
Europe of war and aggression thank you
then a Grazia to teeth thanks very much
to all members who took part in the
debate I now turn to jean-claude Juncker
president of the Commission to reply to
the comments which have been made
jean-claude go ahead Monsieur president
Madam President ladies and gentlemen
colleagues I spoke I believe for more
than an hour was no mean feat for you it
was even more difficult for me because I
have a rather painful sciatica
I have to rest up I'm afraid so I won't
be able to answer you in great detail
but what I will say is as follows the
Commission where it's already taken
initiatives it will continue to work
towards making legislation for example
on social issues the council and the
Parliament have seen a whole range of
initiatives submitted to them and I
don't need to list them here because
those texts have been forwarded to you
so it's not the Commission if you like
that is responsible for the seconding of
workers directives not having been
reviewed yet and indeed I think the same
would apply to a number of other
proposals
you would do well to read the letter of
intention that mr. Timmons and I sent to
the Parliament president over a number
of pages we described in detail the
Commission's intentions and we would
like to involve the Parliament and the
council very closely in the work that
will be done between now and the 24th of
October and after that that being the
date when the work programme for the
Commission is adopted and I hope that
we'll be able to work together ha moment
harmoniously and I hope that we'll wrap
up the year with a joint declaration on
the work programme of the three
presidents of the three institutions and
I apologize for having to leave now
grasses include the deep acceptance
thank you
jean-claude we can send a doctor around
if you like to and take care of you so
that you can always be at full strength
and answer all of the questions that we
have Louis would like to thank vice
president mogherini for the extreme
endurance that she showed in plenary
yesterday now the final round of
speeches ladies and gentlemen and the
first speaker in mr. Cena do not Thank
You president I listened to what you
said mr. Yunker very carefully and it
sounded as if you pranic promising
paradise to us in Europe but if you look
at what the president European
Commission has done is produced
unemployment poverty migration and it's
failed to address any of these problems
as well as the possible entry of
Islamist terrorists into Europe we need
to have a more people centered approach
to Europe people are not happy with the
way things are going we're fed up with
the disastrous results of your
globalized policies we have
democratically elected governments in
Poland and Hungary and they are giving
in the interests of their people the
Greeks the poles the hungry Hungarians
including the Brits who voted to leave
the European Union don't want more or
less Europe they wants a more democratic
Europe a safer Europe one that respects
national sovereignty and respects other
member states
thank you the graph
for [ __ ] recessed dr. betta Hart
Smith mr. president some seem to be
saying that things are getting better in
the European Union they're closing their
eyes or living in never-never land is
the mr. countries are sending large
numbers of people to our shores and
every day met or women and children are
raped by immigrants in our cities by
immigrants of Islamic origin there's no
safety or security European Union and
this parmitt is full of bleeding hearts
you still closing your eyes to the
dangers of Islam and you're spending
millions for the coast guard and
defending our borders and it's not
enough there's a problem
debt is a problem of unemployment and
the European Union is losing market
share internationally so things aren't
going great in the European Union in the
interim the UK has taken to a lifeboat
and left at the Titanic
Eastern countries are engaging in and
countries near us are engaging in all
sorts of dictatorial acts and witch
hunts social failure economic failure
security feed mr. Juncker has done a
runner
so really stop with this electoral
propaganda and just stop this project
which has just been a failure
mr. pack says for the permanent cam
president rumpus all Anam Cara Brito
Parliament our Oslo and Thank You
president since the after the Second
World War the British MP Leon Emery
criticized the British government and
said that mr. Chamberlain had crumbled
now you have spent far too long here go
get out he said to Chamberlain I don't
want to say the same thing to mr. Yunker
but I would just remind him of it those
who had tried to teach lessons to the
countries of Eastern Europe should stop
now I myself am not much of a seaman but
I don't think one can rely on the winds
to reach top speed Oh
[Music]
mr. Lueck in today's debate president we
didn't hear any self-criticism about the
impact of austerity policies imposed on
ordinary people and there's no way you
can move forward a new social project
secondly we've heard a lot about
democracy but I think that the
combination of a single president in the
Commission and the council we don't know
who's got our points this person and
transforming the stability pact into a
European Monetary Fund when we know how
the IMF works the International Monetary
Fund is a very worrying development
because we're gonna see simultaneous
centralization of power and stricter
oversight of Member States budgets so
it'll be more austerity there's nothing
good to come from that quarter and the
idea of that being a more democratic
Europe is simply not correct Thank You
mr. hofstadt the most important things
that we ourself confuse our leaders at a
European level we can choose our
national leaders that's the most
important point and I hope that the GUI
will support the idea of transnational
list which will express this dream will
have and the ability to decide who lead
zero have only two conclusions president
mr. de Graaff says it goes back to a
European you and I think it goes back
with the populist and the nationalist in
European Union he makes it he makes a
mistake problems are in his movement for
the moment not where the European Union
is even saying that no there is no
increase for example in the number of
jobs when everybody knows that there is
an increase in the numbers of jobs in
the European Union and my second
conclusion mr. Tomas is that is
hopefully you have seen here in the
center of this house a broad support for
the program and business program that
mr. Juncker has presented and you have
to take that on board and use that as a
tool to words or Member States and to
the council so that from their side
there will be also the same ambitious
and support for that ambitious program
thank you one or even a good cop mr.
LaHood go nuclear bombs awesome well I
won't hide the fact that I'm a little
bit surprised that President Juncker
didn't say much in terms of the
conclusions to be drawn from brexit I
mean I think that brexit is a great loss
to the Union and if I did think that I
would expect the President to tell us
what he'd done to balance out breaks it
on the other hand he didn't say that
it's good and it's a success I don't
think it's a success I think it's a
failure
now mr. younger has suggest said he's
suggested a number of scenarios and that
there's been a discussion and a debate
what debate a debate is when you don't
know the end conclusion but we already
have a conclusion now we've got a fait
accompli these conclusions are just more
of the same old same old more Europe
from all Europe is that a solution are
we really being treated seriously when
you tell us that is this really a debate
a debate means putting forward arguments
and replying to arguments just recall
the expressions used to describe those
who have a different point of view today
we heard idiots virus viruses we heard
extremists we even heard them being
accused of taking money for their views
is that as discussion if it carries on
like that we all know where we're going
to end up more Europe one president one
Minister to do this everyone's been
saying let's keep going forwards no
let's not keep going forwards let's look
at what's happening somebody's quite
rightly said that it's not true
that breaking rules only applies to
their mothers it happens here too it
happens within the EU rules are
criminally contravened by institutions
of the EU including the European
Commission which also itself breaks
rules people are also addicted to double
standards hits there are parties and
institutions that are allowed to do
whatever they like and get away with it
scot-free and then there are the weaker
players in this game who aren't allowed
to do much at all let's clean up our own
put our own house in order first let's
begin with the renovation sort of
Commission let's begin by getting the
Commission's house in order and then we
can start thinking of building wonderful
other institutions but let's first of
all cure the illness that is raging in
the European institutions at the moment
and as quickly as possible please these
sake based on the battery given the
importance of this debate colleagues and
that we have been flexible in terms of
speaking time in the debate
theoretically Greens have used up all of
their available time but if scar Keller
or mr. Lambrix want to say something for
one minute I'll give them the floor but
we shall have a minute cath we'd say
Julis
I was leading up to date of how it was
looking my can't that's very kind of you
president mister panetta momentous stay
around that's no bad thing mr.
Timmerman's I've listened to what your
boss has to say I nobody wants to do
he's he's saying about that there'll be
a Europe with no second-class citizens
only right but today some of our
citizens have to keep on eating products
which you don't want to ban because of
better regulation there are high-rises
on fire though or would that have been a
fire like in the UK because we don't
want to do anything about anti [ __ ] of
or fire retardants and national stands
are the good enough so simply quite
simply I would ask the Commission to
make a gesture and heed the words of
your boss thank you now Gianni pittella
for the S&T group thank you president I
believe that a Europe which works in the
interest of its citizens zero but that
doesn't work properly runs counter to
those interests and simply increases
citizens disaffection let's be honest
there are forces in Europe and in this
house which are working so that Europe
doesn't work properly so as to gain from
this back home it is X opposite of what
we want we want a visionary project for
Europe a Europe that works and responds
to the problems of its citizens we want
a parliament that has legislative powers
please
what kind of parliament in the world
doesn't have the possibility of
proposing legislation there's no
Parliament in the world like this apart
from the European Parliament that would
help citizens that would help democracy
if that were to be the case secondly
transnational agreements
I am happy to work with the EPP as far
as transnational lists are concerned
it's a new form for European democracy a
president of the Commission directly
elected by the citizens and the
President of the Council the same two
hats principle that's a good idea in
this case but without being voted on by
the people we have to be careful that
needs the people's participation needs
to be guaranteed a kind of European
federal system in terms of the economy a
European Federal Bank all of this needs
to be hedged about with European culture
because European culture is what holds
Europe together it's a dream it's
something we want but also a political
program for us it's the Utopia but a
possible utopia Thank You mr. Weber
surgical excision gentlemen